300 livres 6 jours et dix personnes
mobilisées le salon du livre de la
jeunesse de montreuil est le rendez vous
annuel pour rue du monde la maison
d'édition vicinaux asie sera pour la
vingtième année consécutive
c'est la principale manifestation
en europe autour de la littérature
jeunesse et aux nous y participons
depuis le premier salon de 1996 où nous
avons débarqué sur un stand de 1 m de
large avec un livre le grand livre des
droits de l'enfant illustré par pef les
médias parlent très peu du livre
jeunesse un très très peu
je crois qu'il n'a pas perçu en france
qu'il y avait un livre jeunesse
extrêmement brillant qui fait justement
briller les yeux du monde entier tous
les professionnels du livre et de
l'enfance il se crée ici des livres
extraordinaires beaucoup douze mille
nouveaux titres par an nous on n'en fait
qu'une trentaine à là dedans
ce sont les originaux du dernier livre
que nous publions bonnes nouvelles du
monde et donc nathalie novi grande
illustratrice nous a confié ses images
qu'elle a réalisée à la suite bien sûr
dans la lecture du texte en 20 ans rue
du monde a édité plus de 400 titres la
maison est né d'un financement
participatif un crowfunding avant leurs
20 ans un gros chantier beaucoup de
travail 425 livres le réaliser depuis ce
jour où j'ai de 1996 où j'ai un peu
follement décidé de créer une maison
d'édition alors que j'étais auteur de
livres jeunesse j'avais publié une
cinquantaine de livres dans de
nombreuses maisons d'édition
invitation au voyage découverte des
enfants du monde entier rue du monde
amène à réfléchir aux droits des plus
jeunes chaque année la maison offre 5000
livres secours populaire français un
engagement qu'il sera partagé lors des
cinq jours du salon de montreuil